doncaster a town built on cold it was
mined here for a century and a half this
was almost the last place in Britain to
close all of its calories and having
powered the Industrial Revolution it's
now playing a part in another profound
change in our society so say hello to
the future of shopping these are robots
in an Amazon warehouse on the edge of
Doncaster they collect items move them
around and prepare them for distribution
there are no humans in this area the
process is entirely run by machines
this whirling ballet is a sign of the
future for our largest retailers robots
roaming around a giant warehouse to
fulfill our orders as quickly as
possible and this won't diminish you
don't uninvent this kind of
extraordinary technology so the question
is how will all this impact our society
round the corner another Amazon
warehouse vast and populated by people
it covers a million square feet the size
of 15 football pitches 87% of the UK is
within a four-hour drive of here it is
the perfect place for fulfilling orders
made online we do have automation in a
number of our fulfillment centers there
are still certain types of roles that
robotics or automation cannot do do I
see a future with no humans I see a
future where there is greater
interaction between both automation and
people Amazon's a company valued at
nearly a trillion dollars with enough
money to build as many warehouses and
robots as it wants so can anyone really
compete against all this in the middle
of Doncaster a very different face to
this changing retail world ray and
Sandra are closing the doors on their
carpet shop there are no robots here
just memories of cashing customers it's
been in the family for
eighty-five years we'd either got to
make a decision that to leave while
staying we decided that if we stayed by
the time Christmas came would be owing
money so we decided that now is the time
to leave this shop wasn't killed by
competition from the internet not
directly anyway but by a drop in the
number of people shopping on these
streets coming through these doors a
striking contrast to former decades
people had won in the hand to spend them
days nowadays they go to the
supermarkets buy everything under one
roof shoppings just changed and I can't
see ever going back to how it were but
sounds like Doncaster it's a chronic
problem we shop in different ways now
online yes but also in big modern
shopping centers often out of town in
the heart of Doncaster you'll never fall
from a vacant shopping the town centers
probably a bit too big here and you know
fundamentally dominated by by the large
shopping centre and therefore you will
see more voids and vacant units sort of
particularly spreading out from the
epicenter I have a horrible feeling that
may be worse to come that is an
unsettling vision and maybe it reflects
an uncomfortable truth Danka stares got
the same population as rather about ten
miles away but here they've got twice as
many shops and one in five of them is
standing empty so there's a place like
this just to have too many shops Sky
News commissioned analysis from the
local data company into the state of our
high street it showed that the number of
occupied shops in the UK reached a peak
of almost a hundred and ninety three
thousand in the early months of 2018 but
that number is now falling and here's
why while the number of empty shops was
on the decline after the financial
crisis it's now rising again perhaps not
as much as you'd expect though and
that's because a growing number of shops
are being demolished entirely or
converted into other uses such as home
or offices the shops that are left
though what Canadia more than just
survive how do they find a way to thrive
Rachael Whittaker opened her Jam and
chutney shop just under a year ago her
plan was to focus intensely on the local
market amazon's not going to go away and
it shouldn't go away because it offers
people something that they really do
need but if we want to compete with that
we have to say as you say it's an
experience you come here and you get
something completely different than if
you're clicking online because I shop
online but I also support local
businesses I would never even dream of
say buying my meat or my vegetables
online because I've got a market on my
doorstep maybe that's the key town
centers have to be about more than just
shopping
perhaps it has to become more well fun
this site used to be the Danka ster
branch of BHS department store it's been
transformed into a trampolining and
activity center all in the middle of a
shopping now it's a question of looking
at perhaps looking at the opportunity
and thinking you know what service can I
provide or what goods and services can I
provide that Amazon can't that main
keeps coming up amazon isn't the only
online giant in fact it only accounts
for 2% of retail sales in this country
but it has become a byword for online
shopping and also a symbol of how the
traditional retail world is being
morphed by global companies with opaque
tax arrangements we pay all of our taxes
that we are expected to pay we followed
the rules and we always will do that
whether there is a question around a
future tax or change to tax is a
question which is best answered by the
politicians Britain shopkeepers and
their communities do face challenging
times technology is racing forward as
we've revealed the high street has
reached its peak it will change and
become smaller but it won't disappear
like Doncaster itself retailers will
just need to embrace the art of
reinvention
Adam Parsons Sky News Doncaster